Oh
shall L ever see
okay so I'm going to start the meeting
and ask the photographs to leave and
clear the room
okay so we are going to start this
extraordinary meeting of envy and I
would like to welcome Attenberg
and I will ask you to put your earphones
on if you want to hear me in French
because I'm going to switch to French
for this intuitive in directory remark
you see a word I'm very pleased to
welcome you here Greta turn back to this
committee of the European Parliament at
the invitation of President Sir solely
you came here already in April 2019 I
think so it's about ten months ago you
delivered a message to us which told us
that we were not doing enough and of
course you were right I'd like to start
with a quotation the climate crisis
threatens the survival of humanity we
cannot eliminate the hypothesis of
catastrophic damage that would lead to
the disappearance of human life as we
know it well this is a quotation from
greater but not exactly a quotation by
Greta toon bag because it actually comes
from JP Morgan bank
well they the facts of the fact and it
doesn't matter who is saying them some
of you in the room will love add or
greater tune back others of you in the
room may hate greater turn back but
whatever you feel the facts are the
facts scientists science and we are in
the process of losing the battle of the
climate we've invited you today and
you've accepted our invitation and
that's not just to play the role of a
whistleblower rather you're here to help
us to build a solution your role
which you carry out in an exceptional
manner very effectively is to pass on
the message to sound the alarm bells
that's what you have been doing for
months now and I believe you've met
hundreds of political decision makers
you've taken their photo with you they
say that well what you're saying is
fantastic but then they've done
absolutely nothing afterwards that is
not the mood here in the European
Parliament that is not the mood in
Europe today as it certainly is not the
prevailing mood in the Environment
Committee of the European Parliament
when we hear the alarms coming from the
bankers of JPMorgan and from the
scientists we have to play do our bit we
have to be credible scientifically
credible in financial terms credible in
industrial terms
everyone has their role to play in this
I am deeply convinced that what we need
is the energy of our young people no
society is transformed no society can
respond to the kind of challenge we face
on the climate if we do not take onboard
the energy coming from our young people
and you embody that in Europe and at the
world's level but great do not be
mistaken today you sit before the
Environment Committee which is right at
the forefront of the climate struggle
you're not here in the white house with
Donald Trump you're not in Australia
with a climate skeptic Prime Minister
you're not with Bolson era in Brazil
you're in Europe we are building the
Green Deal it's important that we should
have energy but it has to be a positive
energy an energy that brings society
with it that brings onboard even the
people who are most reticent so after
these words of introduction I'll give
you the floor for about 10 minutes
lish then we will have the coordinators
for each political group and I will ask
them of course to stick to the time
allocated to them let's start with the
Euro speech for around 10 minutes
hi hi
my name is Greta timbale I am a climate
activist and a part of the Friday's for
future movement and for over one and a
half years we have been sacrificing our
education to protest against your
inaction and in September over seven and
a half million people all around the
world took to the streets demanding you
to unite behind the science in order to
give us a safe future then in November
2009 teen the European Parliament
declared climate and environment
emergency you said that the EU would
lead against the existential threat of
the climate crisis and this was
wonderful news when your children set
off the fire alarm you went outside took
a look and smell the air you stated that
yes the house is actually burning this
was no false alarm
but then you went back inside finished
your dinner and watched your movie and
went to bed without even calling the
fire department I'm sorry but this makes
no sense at all when your house is on
fire you don't wait a few more years to
start putting it out and yet this is
what the Commission are proposing today
when the EU presents this climate law
and net zero by 2050 you indirectly
admit surrender that you are giving up
giving up on the Paris agreement giving
up on your promises and giving up on
doing everything you possibly can to
ensure a safe future for your own
children because this law
is based on an insufficient co2 budget
that in reality gives us much much less
than a 50% chance of limiting the global
average temperature rise to below 1.5
degrees Celsius and any climate law or
policy that is not based on the current
best available science and does not
include the global aspect of equity nor
the annual emissions reductions needed
starting now will be completely
insufficient of course such law sends a
strong signal that real sufficient
action is taking place when in fact it
is not the hard truth is that neither
the awareness nor the politics needed
are anywhere in sight we are still in a
crisis that has never once been treated
as a crisis we do have lots of brilliant
solutions we have unprecedented wealth
and financial assets we have a lot of
goodwill and countless of people ready
to do everything they can to help what
we do not have is awareness leadership
and above all time all rapidly
disappearing carbon budgets are the
bottom line that sums up the current
best available climate science no matter
how insufficient they may be as they
don't include tipping points most
feedback loops equity nor additional
warming hidden by air pollution they are
still the most reliable road map we have
to safeguard the future living
conditions for humankind but the
contents of these budgets have never
been taken into account in today's
politics it has never been communicated
in mainstream media and yet here you are
trying to create laws and policies once
again
ignoring it pretending that your plan or
policy disregarding the United science
will somehow so the biggest crisis
humanity has ever faced pretending
that's a law that no one has to follow
is a law and pretending that you can be
a climate leader and still go on
building and subsidizing new fossil fuel
infrastructure
[Applause]
pretending that leaving out the global
aspect of climate justice and equity
won't risk breaking up the entire Paris
agreement pretending that empty words
will make this emergency go away
this must come to an end no policy plan
or deal will be nearly enough as long as
you just continue to ignore the co2
budget which applies for today we don't
just need goals for 2030 or 2050 we
above all need them for 2020 and for
every following year to come we need to
start cutting our emissions drastically
at the source
now you're distant targets will mean
nothing if high emissions continue like
today's business as usual even for just
a few more years because that will use
up our remaining carbon budgets before
you will able have the chance to deliver
on your 2030 or 2050 goals and since
these negative emissions technologies
that this law of fully relies on don't
exist today at scale and perhaps never
will we simply need to change our
behavior change our society and this is
the uncomfortable truth that you cannot
escape no matter how badly you want to
or how hard you try and the longer you
keep running away from that truth the
bigger your betrayal towards your own
children the EU must lead the way you
have the moral obligation to do so and
you have a unique economical and
political opportunity to become a real
climate leader you yourselves declared
that we are in the climates and
environment emergency you said this was
an existential threat
now you must prove that you mean it and
we will not be satisfied with anything
less than a science-based pathway which
gives us the best possible chance to
safeguard the future living conditions
for Humanity and life on Earth as we
know it
anything else is surrender this climate
law is surrender because Nature doesn't
bargain and you cannot make deals with
physics
and we will not allow you to surrender
on our future thank you
[Applause]
thank you so I'm going to give the floor
to the political groups represented by
the coordinators in env starting with
the EPP with petty reserved for six
minutes Thank You chair and thank you
Rita for your very impressive statement
and for all the engagement of the last
month's for me it's important that you
represent millions of young people in
Europe and all over the globe and I meet
Fridays for future people in my
constituency very constantly and I'm
always very impressed how deep their
knowledge is and how strong their
personal commitment is for example I met
a young girl that traveled to a Fridays
for future event 25 kilometers only but
she took three hours because she was not
ready to ask somebody to drive her by
car but she used the public transport
and I met many other examples the
science is clear when we just implement
the commitment that all the parties gave
for the Paris agreement that temperature
will rise probably above three degrees
and this is linked to a very high risk
that we cross the dangerous tipping
points like the melting of the Greenland
ice fields or the melting of the
permafrost in the northern hemisphere
and that's why I understand the
motivation of your generation my
children are only a few years older if
we don't act soon there will be a
situation maybe in 3040 years where your
generation and your children are not
able to control climate change anymore
and that's why all the parties have to D
more than they committed in the Paris
agreement all parties to the agreement
for my political groups the EPP group I
would highlight three concrete points
that we want to implement
first of all we want to invest more in
research and innovation for example to
decarbonize industry I think it must be
possible to keep the industry but to
make them cleaner and climate friendly
there we should also show the way for
other major economies like China and
India and we were successful together
it's a huge priority for the European
Parliament the problem is the Member
States the finance ministers and the
heads of state are proposing to cut the
budget for innovation and that's why I
think we all need to fight that the
Member States will accept their
responsibility second point we have a
huge problem in the European forests
because of climate change we have
draught we have heat waves the last two
years first owner are no longer getting
any benefit from their business and
forest is important for the climate it's
the most important sink that we have in
Europe and it's also a good example that
economic problems and climate problems
go hand in hand if we don't tackle this
so it point and here I'm very determined
I think we need a European carbon price
we need a carbon price also in the areas
where we don't have one for example
transport and building and I think to
get there we can talk about text but
this needs unanimous decision with all
the Member States so it's almost
impossible that's why I very much
support in ETS also for this sectors the
best would be a separate one and I think
we have to talk about this I don't think
it's possible to get too ambitious
climate targets without a European comet
prize and I would also like to hear your
opinion here now to the climate law I
understand your message very well but I
have to say that I think the climate law
is ambitious
it is ambitious to go for carbon
neutrality and is also ambitious to go
up in the 2030 target even if we go only
up from 40 to 50% that is a major step
and my concern is I don't know any other
major economy all over the world that is
considering such a step and this is my
last point you cross the Atlantic and
you met many many people in the United
States Canada and all over Latin America
and I would like to understand what you
learned there how can we motivate these
countries and also others like South
Africa China India Japan that they will
increase their NDC I talked to the
European Commission yesterday and
there's no major economy only small
states which I admire a lot Morocco
Costa Rica ATO Pia but they will not
change the major bulk of emissions so we
need these major emitters and of course
we need to lead by example that is a
very clear answer
but I don't think it's this is enough so
how can we convince other major
economies in Latin America and all over
the American continent but also for the
rest of the world because what I think
is very clear the science is clear we
need to do more but we need to do more
globally and that's a major challenge
that we have to address thank you very
much thank you we are going to move to
you - guten on the iPod coordinator for
a sandy group and also the reporter for
the climate low so for five minutes
tack good far on there thank you very
much chair and hello Greta are they
speaking Swedish it's an honor that
you're a Swede and it feels great to
speak Swedish today thanks for coming
here and we want of course to reduce
emissions
get rid of them entirely your voice is
strong and I can really feel a wave go
through the room when you open your
mouth and I think the standing of ocean
shows how grateful we are for your tough
work bringing a generation together I'm
have been an elected member of this
assembly for six years now and I get the
feeling there's a real before and after
the Friday's for future movement and I'd
really like to thank you for that
but I have listened to you carefully
today I've understood that you want more
and that we've got a big challenge ahead
of us that's clear I think it's what you
said is right we're discussing the e use
new measures for reducing emissions not
just the climate law that's being
presented today and I'm the reporter for
that law in this house Europe has the
responsibility and the resources to
engage in a real transition and we need
to ensure that that's done but we also
need to ensure that our transition is
just and covers all sectors and brings
all citizens on board our work has to
ensure that we work together with a lot
of different sectors but also other
parts of the world and the EU evidently
has a loud voice that should be heard
we're all sitting in the same boat but
the EU has extra responsibility to
reduce its emissions right now and we
have to show that we're aware of that so
it's important that we should be a good
example and we can influence the rest of
the world by showing that we mean it
seriously we're by reducing our own
admissions more rapidly it's not just a
question of justice but also ambition we
have to be more ambitious and that's
something that you've raised frequently
in your speeches including today well
the target of being climate neutral by
2050 is one that we can't just be
satisfied with we have to be moving
faster and we need to be setting for
more ambitious goals for today and for
2030
so I do believe that we should be doing
more I do agree with you to the climate
law that the Commission was presented
today isn't in line with the science it
isn't what you would like to see right
now but I hope that we in the European
Parliament will be able to do more to
try and ensure that things are happening
faster that we're more ambitious and
that we can achieve our ambition so that
we could genuinely lead the world I will
be trying to do that as a reporter on
this file I hope that the European
Parliament can be the the force that
really fights for this in the
institutions and I hope that this can
all happen before Glasgow so that we
could ensure that the world will hear
and that we can really be provide the
good example the climate law has to
build upon a system where there is a
quite carbon budget that fits in with
the targets on a mission reduction so
that we can see how the work is
progressing we are working very hard and
I can promise you the will will struggle
we will fight and we get help from your
work that you put pressure on this
Parliament our objective is that science
and scientific advice should be at the
forefront there has to be the basis for
the EU climate legislation but I don't
want to mislead you don't want to tell
you that this is going to be easy there
are very conservative forces here in
this house who were against the climate
action and against you personally
so there are conservative forces here
that want to water down the work that
we're doing I hope you're aware of this
that there is a big divide in this house
between those who do want to do
something and those who don't
I don't maybe you know that already but
I thought it's important to say that
when we're all here together in the same
room science speaks a clear language
that's something we all know we're
coming towards a turning point is
becoming more and more difficult for us
to implement the Paris agreement fully
there's no doubt that more has to be
done
I mean you know the climate worked
better than most people you know that we
have tightened up the goals on renewable
energy on energy efficiency on emissions
trading emissions from the transport
sector there's a lot of potential there
are a lot of opportunities there for new
efforts that are in line with the
climate neutral economy so that we can
create a better life after the
transition I'm absolutely convinced then
that has to be our objective and I want
to ensure that that's actually going to
happen
we as Social Democrats want to be very
clear the Social Democratic group here
in the European Parliament so-called S&D
group we will be constantly focusing on
equality in justice the just transition
for us it's very important to ensure
that welfare security and climate policy
all work together so then we will get a
better safer Society and we want the
work to go faster to conclude I just
wanted to say that you are a
representative of the millions of young
people who like you are fighting for the
climate fighting to ensure a future for
us on this planet I would like to thank
you and all of the young people who are
following your footsteps who are taking
their own initiatives they are telling
the truth to our society we need that
you have already transformed the debate
in this house and absolutely sure of it
a group want more we will be putting
pressure on and we will be very tough we
want to do more and we promise you that
we will struggle thanks for coming here
okay let's say that I give you one extra
30 minute for your role of reporter
otherwise I won't be able to manage the
time so let's move to renew and new
stores thank you yeah in scope well I'll
keep going in Swedish saying as we share
a language hi greater welcome back last
time you were here a lot of the
politicians in this room were more
interested in going on the electoral
campaign trail and when politicians are
out on the campaign trail they tend to
promise a bit too much and then they try
to go back on it afterwards but in any
case we have made a small effort making
some improvements before the cop 25 we
took a decision on increasing the level
of ambition for co2 emissions for 2030
so we're now going up to 55% well you're
telling us that still not enough but
compared to the previous goal a 40% then
it's a significant step forward I also
had rather a tough debate on the climate
emergency many voted in favor but many
voted against there was a lot of
criticism of our approach at that time
where we were called alarmist but if you
look around the world of what's
happening the forest fires the floods
all of these phenomena maybe we weren't
far from the truth when we declared a
climate emergency if you look at this
sea between Sweden and Finland the
Baltic then you can see how the Baltic
is being influenced having a milder
winters the salt content of the Baltic
Sea is falling
and it's going to dramatically quickly
and that is going to be a major stress
on biodiversity I'd like to wish a
special welcome to you on behalf of an
MEP who can't be here today
Kathleen's aboard she was the first
woman to sail single-handed around the
world she wanted to pass on her
greetings because you have crossed the
Atlantic the oceans absorb about 50% of
all of the increase in heat in the world
these huge quantities of heat that the
oceans are absorbing are going to be
very difficult to deal with and it's
going to be a long-term effort it's
going to be a big effort to achieve the
targets by 2050 and after that as well I
would be would be 105 by that date I
don't know what side of the lawn I will
find myself on well a lot of politicians
politicians are taking this too lightly
you might have seen some people on
Twitter on the other side of the
Atlantic you think that a tweet can
solve the problems that we face of
course Donald Trump is a bad example for
all of us
what we need is innovation and when we
talk about innovation there are some
countries that are doing quite well if
you look at the the innovative countries
in Europe its Sweden Denmark and Finland
and it's the countries with a good
educational systems that are taking the
lead well you're skipping school of
course but I think it's excellent that
we have a good school system I realized
that you have more important things to
do of course but I'm very happy to see
that you continuing with to put on
political pressure to get otherwise we
wouldn't get the movement we've seen in
Brussels
thank you
next group is ID and Sid yes our journey
for three minutes
majority good afternoon hello Greta this
week the European Parliament is closed
off to visitors in some cases some MEP s
and assistants but today the parliament
is open to Greta and other people it
seems that maybe the environmentalists
can't get the coronavirus I hold young
people who believe in something in high
esteem people like you Greta that poor
passion and commitment into an ideal
however it's becoming more and more
clear that Greta is being explote
exploited even by the European
Commission that is trying to improve its
image but unlike those who are
applauding because she's in vogue I
don't want to be false I think that the
battle carried out by the fundamentalist
and so-called environmentalists is
hypocritical it's wrong and it punishes
ordinary people it's hypocritical
because I see a lot of young people in
the streets but I wonder whether it be
in favor of a happy D growth how many
young people would give up their
smartphone and 5g how many young people
would give give up taking a plane for a
nineteen euro a flight how many people
young people would give up fast food and
soft drinks or washing their clothes as
little as possible or not putting on the
AC on mics how many people would give up
that in order to join the religion of
environmentalism and what about
coronavirus are you really in favor of
it because it reduces pollution in China
because less businesses that are working
means less pollution but more
unemployment and more poverty I'm also
saying that this battle is wrong because
you're targeting the wrong people
Greta and Co are organizing
demonstrations and marches in the West
but where despite limitations for years
we've been working on environmentalist
policies but these environmentalists
never mentioned China India
never organized marches in these
countries in China they have projects
for a fossil fuel plants up to 2030 in
India there are seven seven they have
seven out of ten cities of the most
polluting in the world and then it's
against the ordinary people because we
have plastic stacks sugar attacks and
it's ordinary people that bear the cost
ordinary people and citizens are being
accused of carrying out criminal
offenses because maybe they want to
continue eating meat or because they
want to have a house and maybe believe
it or not want a car the risk is that
the fact you're taxing people and you
have these ideas could have a huge
social impact to have to want to have a
zero-emission society could lead to
poverty and it would also mean that
developing countries would not be able
to develop but I'm not saying that there
isn't pollution and that we shouldn't
reduce it but we need to have an honest
scientific conversation
the Chairman interrupts there are people
exploiting Bretta I believe that the
Commission has to stop using ideological
the chair interrupts you gave extra time
to others this is a democracy god we got
the message thank you that's a good four
degrees thank you very much and I will
just use the mic and you can hear me
even then already first of all welcome
icater timber welcome back but also
welcome everyone in this room who are
showing great interest in all the
climate policies that we are trying to
get off the ground here we've never seen
so much crowd here so maybe we can keep
up those numbers because we need them
when we are doing and when we are
dealing with the climate law you're
absolutely right and I'm very thankful
for you to really put back the science
into perspective because that is the
crucial point here every time when we
hear speeches
all kind of politicians talking about
how important climate and the climate
emergency we as greens have always said
it's not about the words it's about the
action and unfortunately we would have
loved to see the European Commission
also stepping up its plates when they
came forward with their Green Deal we
were hoping that the Commission would
now really turn the Green Deal into
action today they presented the climate
law and it is outright disappointing
this year should be the year about
increasing our emissions and pay Talisa
you're absolutely right we need to
increase our ambitions and your question
how to do that by showing that we can do
it that we are doing it but if now the
European Commission is enshrining in its
climate law that it will only come with
a proposal by September to maybe have an
increase of our emissions for 2030 then
we have a big problem because the Paris
agreement was constructed to have every
five years one time a global momentum
and 2020 is the year November 2020 is
the moment in Glasgow where it needs to
happen if we are not ready who will be
will China work on will Japan will India
no not if we're not ready and that now
the European Commission is saying that
we may get a proposal by September it is
endangering the Paris agreement because
if we don't increase our ambitions and
we don't get a global momentum of an
increased level of emissions we will be
stuck for five years on the current path
and the current path is bringing us well
above a warming of three degrees that's
the track we're on and we need to bend
it now and Europe need to take action
and now in the climate law we can have
all kind of nice brussels bubble
discussions about delegated act
implementing act but be aware all those
instruments are being proposed to start
after 2030 that's not the debate we
should be had
the debate we should be having is how
much are we going to increase the action
now and how to create that global
momentum that the world so desperately
needs the November deadline is the clock
is ticking and we need action Thank You
crater for putting the science back in
thank you for all the applause but now I
need you also to create the action not
only the applause
[Applause]
thank you for easier people short key
mr. chair mr. steamed colleagues today
marks a major milestone under the Green
Deal with the publication of the
European climate law which legally in
France the 2050 climate neutrality
target on the other end I have some
serious reservations about the
Commission proposal to revise the old
post 2030 climate targets via delegated
acts which are a very weak legal
instrument and the for ineffective in my
opinion to be very frank well moreover
given the breadth of the European Green
Deal it is imperative that all the
policy initiatives are throughly impact
assessed especially considering they
increase 2030 targets to be very frank
this year grouper is opposing increasing
on the gas emission reduction targets
also because it would undermine legal
regulatory certainty has expressed
several times by the previous Commission
in order to cement the ECR position I
would like to state the following number
one do not change the targets I would
like well with stay with the Paris
agreement number two focus on impact
assessment from a technical
socio-economic an industrial point of
view we want more in-depth planning and
less rhetoric and climate symbolism
number three put pressure on third
parties to follow our path they already
mention of several my colleagues but we
thought a global teamwork and I'm
referring again to the US China in India
especially the European effort will have
no significant impact on the global
climate and will cause the destroyer of
our economy I would like to conclude in
a slightly
a conventional way if I may first of all
I personally wish to thank mr. Burt for
hearing Porter role in raising public
awareness on this fundamental topic at
the same time I would like to give an
advice as a father given advice to a
daughter go back to school and go back
to a normal life
your childhood is as precious as the
climate and if you don't do something
about it you will lose it forever if if
we do not do anything about the climate
we will lose it forever
thank you very much she knows more about
science more than a lot of us Sylvia
Maddock for the GUI Thank You chair I
will also be speaking Swedish thought
there what do you mean samus probe well
we've got a common language hi Greta
welcome great to see you here first of
all on behalf of my group the goo Engl I
wanted to thank you for everything
you've done you've inspired millions of
people around Europe
you've given a voice to the young people
who want more more from our political
decision-makers I really wanted to thank
you for the work you've done it makes
our work easier because we are trying to
work hard on the climate now that we
meet here today I mean I see that
there's quite a lot of hypocrisy in the
room the Parliament has got all of these
scientific knowledge it requires it can
take the decisions that are required
we've all got the science the advice the
knowledge that is required but what we
need is courage and political will to
actually take the necessary steps I hope
that your speech here today is taken
seriously because otherwise this is all
just posturing of course it's very nice
to have you see was a symbol for climate
activism but your voice has been very
important
it makes our work easier the
Commission's proposal on a climate law
well we know that it's not ambitious
enough 2030 to reduce emissions by 50
percent that's not enough and that's a
fact it's not an opinion so we have to
raise our targets to the levels that
science is telling us is required and if
we were smart and we would Richie reduce
those targets even further to be
absolutely sure that it'll be enough but
we'll hopefully we'll get some help from
reporter mr. gutten and in trying to
fine-tune the parliaments position we
have to remember what's going on in
other countries too we're saying yes the
EU is doing more than it's ever done
previously but that doesn't mean that
we're doing enough we have to do more
and we stand by your side in this thank
you
again the last speaker will be Eleanor
AV for the non-attached one minutes
Thank You chair you're great and I'm
very happy to meet you here in the
European Parliament I have a call for
you please help us
talking about the lack of transparency
in the European Council the Council of
European Union you might know that here
in European Parliament we work with a
good degree of transparency all
discussions are public and in streaming
amendments are published and translated
this helps democracy and it has often
helper to reach quite ambitious position
in the European Parliament in particular
when it comes to climate and environment
legislation in the past on the contrary
the council where representatives of the
Member States seat is a complete black
hole there are no minutes of the
meetings no recording of Member States
positions on each dossier and behind
closed doors you never know if the
public interest will prevail us or if it
has as it has often de que ISM the
national interest or other interest will
prevail I asked you to help us on this
fight and to raise awareness and I'm
concluding my country Italy today may
the first step in the right direction
setting up at the permanent
representation here in Brussels the
transparency register to monitor meeting
within those interests and hobbies but
much more has to be done to reach full
transparency in council agility process
thus ensuring the ambitions that we
desperately need in the you to fight the
climate crisis thank you
thank you sir unless that number would
like to have the floor again but I don't
think so
I will close the meeting and we will be
with Greta to work and to the very end
of the room so please let's leave space
for her to leave and then I hope that
bass was right and that tomorrow for the
discussion on the climate row in the
next env meeting will be as numerous as
today so thank you for this important
exchange and see you tomorrow for the
env members
just destined at work
[Music]